the virology section allows you to take
the data that was produced by the
pipeline and visualize it
using this interface
this interface shows the reference
genome of the virus the rna virus and
then it shows all the passages here this
right here is
coverage and the coverage is represented
by a line
according to every passage
so you can add and remove passages to
display only the ones that you would be
interested in seeing
you can also go in and check more
specifically
the coverage by number
and it is important because our
calculation of mutation rate is based on
the coverage you can also change the bin
size and see
a higher resolution
by bin size the bin size is by number of
nucleotides
all of the information about every
aspect of this visualization
can be seen by hovering over the eye
button
now if you want to look deeper
for example
this area or this area
they display that there is a pretty high
rate of mutation
and the high rate of mutation
is also adjustable by this slider
so you can make it more sensitive for an
area of mutation that you want to see
of course
more mutations are going to be revealed
by lowering
the
red area
now if we want to check this area we are
opening now a view that shows the
nucleotide
level of resolution
and
you can also move
by bins
using these arrows
now once we've seen
this area of interest we can hover over
it and see
which mutations occur
which nucleotide it is which position
the sequence variability coverage and
like i said which
letter
the mutation occurs
so
now we can close this and also check the
different types of mutations
first of all we are displaying
synonymous and non-synonymous at this
point so we can turn one or the other
off
to check um which remain
and now these are the types of mutations
that our system
calculates
based on adaptation to simplify
beneficial
are the areas that
are beneficial for viral adaptation to
the host
neutral
means that they don't
they occur randomly
detrimental
displays the mutations that
are
not beneficial
to the viral adaptation and lethal means
those mutations actually
change the amino acid to a stop codon
so
those are special types of mutations
now if we only look for example at the
beneficial ones
and we can see how these mutations
are mapped on the 3d structure of the
protein in this protein right here and
we can
make
this image bigger
we can take a look at how these
mutations are mapped on the 3d structure
and
we can also play with the different
views
over here so
this right here shows me
the amino acids colored
in the same way that i see them right
here
and i can also hover over them and see
them displayed
on the 3d structure
as you saw i can also color by ratio by
mutation rate
now i can also render
in spheres if i want to look at that
view
so for example i'm interested in this
area i can see
right here and you also see the area
that is covered in this view
and then
displaying different uh types of
mutations um is done
over here
uh so for example i see this cluster
right here that could be of interest to
me
and that is a way to
um
to see the data in a more visual format
now you can also read a little bit about
this protein and by clicking on this you
actually see the
copy and paste version of the amino
acids if you want to take it further
and
research
so
this
shows
different proteins
the different proteins
could be again viewed you could see
subproteins
and
we can also
see this help
that explains a little bit more about
this visualization tool